all right my talk at the table is an
interview with director ron howard for
our cbs morning's podcast we talked
about his latest movie 13 lives that
takes us through the real life story of
the soccer team you guys remember the
soccer team that was trapped in the cave
in thailand back in 2018 our anna warner
covered it for us here at cbs news
howard also shared what keeps him hooked
on hollywood listen to this
do you still find that same joy that you
had way back then when you were still
just a teenager i'm not an adventuresome
person by nature
but these these films and movies these
to end television shows back in the days
when i was acting but more so when i'm
directing and choosing the subjects that
i want to take on man i'm getting a lot
out of it as a person what's more
thrilling than stepping on a on a set
with you know a bunch of people
dedicated to try to to do something good
to offer audiences something interesting
whether that's because it's hilarious or
surprising or scary or recreates you
know a real moment in in in in our
recent history that is uh you know is is
is inspiring or or you know enthralling
there's a lot more in our podcast so be
sure to check it out but it was really
incredible talking to ron about this
specific story because you might not
remember
how much of a miracle it was that they
were able to rescue these boys and um
and the film the film the filmography
that he does in this film is
breathtaking you can't wait to watch it
yeah it's really really good and of
course we talked a little bit of happy
days because you know i'm a happy days
fanny both
we had a day
yeah you had to